et on va passer au débat de ce club et
on va commencer en parlant de votre
baromètre Frédéric votre institut de
sondage livre qui vient donc de publier
tableau de bord des personnalités
politiques pour le mois de juillet Samir
vous l'avez regardé avec attention
évidemment qui est en tête ce mois-ci
donc bien c'est encore Édouard Philippe
qui reste largement en tête avec 55 %
d'opinion favorables il se détache
toujours clairement des 50 personnalités
politiques testées par l'Ifop pour Paris
Match et SUD RADIO mais il progresse peu
plus 1% par rapport au mois dernier à 9
points derrière lui on trouve Bruno Le
Maire avec 46% de bonnes opinions le
ministre de l'Économie passe de la
quatrième à la deuxième place du
classement François Bayrou fait lui
aussi une belle progression puisqu'il se
hisse de la sixième à la troisième place
avec 45% d'opinion favorables alors en
tête du tableau on trouve donc deux
membres de la majorité présidentielle
issues de la droite est-ce que ça peut
conforter Emmanuel Macron justement dans
une stratégie d'alliance avec la droite
ce résultat en tout cas moi ce qui me
frappe aussi c'est que ce sont trois
successeurs entre bien sûr soyons
prudent possible à la succession de
l'almachron qui n'ont jamais tourné le
dos ou jamais hésité à faire part
d'ambition présidentielle François
Bayrou est un est un triple candidat
voire un quadruple il s'était retiré au
cours de la campagne de 2017 c'est vrai
qu'on est frappé de voir que dans les 10
premières places il y a aucun membre de
la nupes tout à l'heure manuellement par
sur votre plateau Fabien Roussel et elle
passe qui progresse le plus avec Bernard
Cazeneuve donc tes personnalités plutôt
anti-ups mais c'est vrai que aux trois
premières places on a des personnalités
qui sont je dirais surtout pour Édouard
Philippe et Bruno Le Maire compatible
avec les républicains car je crois que
c'est Edouard Philippe qui est pourtant
acquitté les républicains mais qui n'a
jamais eu en 2017 et après l'image d'un
traître qui a la cote de popularité la
plus élevée et sympathisant LR et chez
sympathisant de droite et Isabelle vera
Masson il ne quitte pas la tête de ce
baromètre des personnalités politiques
préférées Édouard Philippe oui
d'ailleurs c'est on peut aussi
interpréter cela comme une
à une certaine accord ou un sentiment
avec la stratégie de renaissance dehors
Macron ce sont quand même des gens qui
ont travaillé avec Emmanuel Macron et
qui
la hausse de leur popularité peut
signifier qu'il y a un certain la
sentiment de la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron donc de droite de gauche en tous
les cas c'est c'est pas à gauche mais ce
n'est pas non plus évidemment les
républicains les plus strictes donc
voici un peu difficile d'interpréter et
puis aussi ce qu'il faut toujours dire
dans ces cas-là c'est que les taux les
montées les les lorsque l'on monte ou
que lorsqu'on est toujours de toute
façon ça signifie quelque chose sur un
notoriété c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on
jugeant bien ou en mal les gens que l'on
connaît c'est un petit peu ce qu'il faut
toujours toujours remarquer alors ce que
dit isabelle est encore plus juste
puisque ce baromètre est à la fois cruel
et sympathique sympathique parce que la
question posée ce n'est pas comme dans
d'autres baromètre de mes confrères une
côte d'avenir une cote de confiance
va-t-il va-t-elle résoudre les problèmes
c'est une cote de bonne mauvaise opinion
mais il est cruel car nous laissons en
clair parce que il y a cette question
est-ce que c'est une critique souvent
juste des sondages d'opinion est-ce que
la personne est connue est-ce que on va
demander la bonne opinion sur une
personne connue sur une personne dont on
ne maîtrise pas tout à fait sa
personnalité et son action on laisse en
clair la possibilité de dire je ne le
connais pas ou je ne la connais pas
suffisamment ce qui fait qu'il y a
beaucoup de personnalités notamment des
ministres même si cette vague d'enquête
est une vague haussière il y a je crois
28 personnalités qui gagnent au moins
deux à trois points c'est une vague qui
est plutôt qui va dans le qui va dans le
sens d'une progression alors même
qu'elle a été faite la semaine qui a
suivi ses émeutes urbaines ça n'a pas
impacté sur une défiance vis-à-vis du
politique mais j'en aurai fini ce qui
frappe dans ce baromètre depuis
maintenant des mois et des mois c'est
qu'il n'y a plus que une seule
personnalité qui a une majorité de
bonnes opinions Édouard Philippe ce
baromètre va fêter ses 20 ans il y a une
dizaine d'années on avait en septembre
2012 je crois 23 personnalités qui
avaient une cote d'opinion majoritaire
en septembre 2017 il pas si longtemps
que ça plus que 8 et là une seule et
unique Édouard Philippe même si Bruno Le
Maire continue de progresser comme
premier ministre bis aux hautes
incontournables de Bercy et il est
tangente maintenant une majorité des
bonnes opinions Édouard Philippe
aujourd'hui c'est un atout pour Emmanuel
Macron ou c'est un concurrent ça l'a
fait bien manuel Macron il peut pas se
représenter est-ce Édouard Philippe il
incarne l'avenir et et
finalement il rend Emmanuel Macron un
peu déjà passé alors j'allais dire pas
le contraire mais un peu différent c'est
on remarque également que plus on
s'éloigne de la vie politique
quotidienne
et plus on monte un peu dans les dans
les opinions on voit pour François
Hollande qui a été tellement souffert du
côté de des opinions il est plutôt pas
mal placé en ce moment donc c'est vrai
que l'éloignement favorise la sympathie
des Français donc je ne sais pas si on
si on peut en tirer des conséquences en
ce qui concerne Emmanuel Macron brune
d'Édouard Philipp conserve cette place
qu'il a depuis quand même pas mal de
temps qui est proche d'Emmanuel Macron
et concurrent d'Emmanuel Macron mais
comme on le sait Emmanuel Macron ne se
représentant pas les choses sont
vraiment tout à fait originales dans le
sens qu'on ne peut difficilement
s'appuyer sur le passé pour comprendre
l'avenir ça vient on va continuer à
regarder ce baromètre parce que derrière
eux il y a des personnalités de droite
mais Rachida Dati est en tête à droite
avec 45% d'opinions favorables elle
occupe la quatrième place juste devant
Nicolas Sarkozy et Xavier Bertrand il
progressent tous les trois et supplante
largement le président de leur partie
les républicains erikiotiques qui lui
occupe que la trentième place avec 30%
d'opinion favorables ou encore les 22%
de Bruno retaillaux patrons des
sénateurs de droite comment s'en sort à
la gauche alors la gauche il semble
qu'elle régresse un peu un François
Hollande passe de la deuxième elle a 7e
place du classement 42% des sondés ont
une bonne opinion d'anciens présidents
ce qu'il place à égalité avec le leader
du Parti communiste Fabien Roussel en
revanche très belle progression de
Bernard Cazeneuve qui fait un bon de 10
places dans le classement pour se hisser
en 11e position l'ancien Premier
ministre de François Hollande qui espère
créer on le sait une alternative à la
nuque à gauche totalise 40% d'opinion
positives et du côté de la nuque
justement on vous le disait les choses
vont un peu moins bien François Ruffin
reste le plus populaire avec 38%
d'opinion favorables il occupe la 15e
place sur 50 personnalités testées
devant Sandrine Rousseau et surtout
devant Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui totalise
30% d'opinion positives ça veut dire
vous avez une question oui tout à fait
la nuque elle semble un petit peu à la
peine dans l'opinion par rapport à la
gauche réforme mise alors est-ce que ça
s'explique parce qu'elle n'arrive pas à
faire émerger de leaders puisque ces
personnalités justement jugent aussi la
capacité à être un leader ou est-ce que
c'est parce que ces idées sont tout
simplement minoritaires je pense que
c'est plutôt la deuxième hypothèse il y
a pas de problème d'incarnation on peut
dire ce qu'on veut de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais c'est une très forte incarnation il
y a des incarnations c'est du côté du PS
du côté de comme gilet vert mais on voit
très bien quand on voit ce classement
que les personnalités les plus Antilles
du peste Fabien Roussel on en parlait
François Hollande mais la case 9 sont en
tête du classement on voit que alors
c'est une vague haussière clémentinottin
Jean-Luc Mélenchon connaisse des
stabilités ou des mouvements à la baisse
et puis très clairement je pense que il
y a un des dégâts d'images pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et la dernière le dernier
épisode c'est ce qui s'est passé au
moment des émeutes urbaines ou beaucoup
d'élus non pas de la dupesse mais plus
précisément de la France insoumise non
pas appelé au calme on refusé d'appeler
au calme je pense à David Guiraud je
pense à Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a dit
qu'on pouvait ne qu'il fallait pas
brûler des écoles et des bibliothèques
donc compris qu'on pouvait brouiller
d'autres choses sans doute d'accord mais
c'est comme ça que ça a été perçu et
très clairement moi je suis frappé je
reprends votre terme d'idées sur de plus
de plus en plus des sujets de plus en
plus nombreux laïcité rapport à la
police le fameux la police tu il y a un
décalage de plus en plus la grande ce
que pensent les sympathisants de gauche
je parle spécifiquement des
sympathisants de gauche le peuple de
gauche et ce que avance les leaders de
la France insoumise et on a quand même
une nupes qui est de plus en plus d'une
sur une gauche radicale qui n'est pas la
ligne de la majeure partie des
sympathisants de gauche c'est ce hiatus
qui fait que dans les enquêtes dans une
voiture européenne le total gauche n'a
jamais été aussi bas et dans un simple
baromètre faut pas lui donner plus de
pouvoir plus d'intérêt qu'il a mais dans
un simple baromètre des personnalités
plutôt orientées à la hausse et ben on
voit des personnalités de la France
insoumise de la nups à la peine
la nuque sort perdons de cette séquence
pour vous Isabelle
l'analyse a été excellente comme ce jour
mais j'ajouterai que la nupesse donc moi
je l'appelle la nuesse je rappelle qu'il
y a le PS dedans
et ne bénéficie pas du débat sur les
retraites alors que ça c'est quand même
un élément intéressant et là ce sondage
aurait pu le révéler et du cerf de
manière ça ça va dans le sens de la
fermeture d'une certaine parenthèse
importante c'est à quel point peut-être
d'ailleurs elle va laisser des traces
cette guerre cette bataille sur les
retraites en ce qui concerne les
personnalités et la dupesse ça ne leur a
pas apparemment bénéficier donc on
pourrait en parler de cette de cet après
débat sur les retraites on a vu qu'il y
a eu des déclarations assez étonnantes à
part du corps ou de certains nombre de
choses peut-être aussi les 100 jours on
va en parler et une manière d'embrayer
sur ces questions là explique tout cela
en tout cas moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est
point le débat sur les retraites qui
étaient pourtant très favorables aux
opposants à la à la retraite il y aura
pas
du tout bénéficier oui je partage
complètement c'est vrai que le premier
accro si je puis dire le premier signe
qui aurait dû nous alerter c'est un pays
qui a massivement soutenu le mouvement
social un pays qui a deux tiers des
Français 70% de mémoire des salariés qui
ne voulaient pas de la retraite à 64 ans
et la gauche n'a pas bénéficié dans la
compétition entre les deux scènes
politiques c'est la scène syndicale qui
a été qui a qui est à Paris beaucoup
plus crédible que la scène parlementaire
et puis c'est vrai que la stratégie de
bordélisation de désordre initiés par
les députés la France insoumise avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui tient les ficelle
si je puis dire n'a pas du tout n'a pas
été du tout du goût des Français et
également d'une partie très importante
des sympathisants de gauche et c'est
vrai que si on fait le bilan à quelques
heures du 14 juillet clairement cette
gauche elle est fi à gauche du peste n'a
pas n'est pas apparu comme opposition la
plus crédible aujourd'hui et encore
c'est toujours rassemblement national
qui apparaît comme l'alternative et
justement je vous fais réagir Isabelle
faire un Masson mais un mot de Marine Le
Pen ça vient elle gagne 4 points mais
avec 42 % d'opinion favorable elle reste
elle a 9e place du classement sur 50
personnalités politiques testées oui je
voulais réagir à ce que vous venez dire
c'est je me demande aussi si cette
violence extrême est très choquante et à
qui a choqué alors là vraiment les
presque tous les Français sauvent la
nupaise n'a pas aussi contribué à
dévaloriser la lutte qui a suivi qui a
accompagné la réforme des retraites
c'est à dire que la violence
qu'elle est français avaient pas mal de
de sympathie en ce qui concerne les
retraites on a vu son autre volet et
c'est devenu peut-être plus moins
acceptable plus critiquable il y a des
comme ça des rencontres dans l'histoire
qui peuvent être étonnantes et jouer
quelque chose un jeu tout à fait
particulier et on s'est posé la question
de savoir du coup qui du RN ou de la
nuque bénéficier de cet après retraite
et de cette page sur les émeutes parce
qu'avec ce baromètre on a une réponse
qui a été dit il y a également Jordan
par des la gagne qui gagne 6 points de
bonnes opinions qui est quasiment au
coût d'un coup avec Marine Le Pen et il
faut le dire maintenant l'incarnation du
rassemblement national c'est un duo qui
est assez complémentaire complémentaire
sociologiquement on va que Jordan par
des là à des scores supérieurs à Marine
Le Pen chez les jeunes chez les ouvriers
mais également chez les cadres
supérieurs et puis sur le discours on a
eu une Marine Le Pen qui a été plutôt si
je puis dire
modéré en surplomb intervenant peu et on
a eu un Jordan Bardella beaucoup plus
radical beaucoup plus incisif invoquant
la chanlie le désordre faisant le lien
automatique en immigration et insécurité
c'est intéressant pour le reste de voir
qu'il y a cette incarnation je pense que
Marine Le Pen reste à candidate
naturelle c'est c'est jamais bon d'être
candidat naturel on sait sur la
Cinquième République pour 2027 mais
clairement il y a une percée il y a un
moment Jordan Bardella
oui on voit bien que dans ce couple il y
a une répartition des rôles good COP
c'est le batcops
la droite extrême qui s'assume et puis
une droite extrême qui se banalise qui
se régularise et effectivement quand on
voit les résultats c'est plutôt positif
pour eux alors moi je suis je comprends
que les émeutes et bénéficié à Marine Le
Pen puisque dans certaines manières ça
va dans le sens de ce qu'elle raconte
mais j'ai été plus surprise pendant le
fait que ça n'avait pas bénéficié
puisque cela à Emmanuel Macron et au
gouvernement qui était sur place parce
que traditionnellement face au désordre
les citoyens
regardent l'exécutif d'une manière un
peu plus positive là apparemment ça va
pas bénéfié on peut se demander si la
non prise de parole d'Emmanuel Macron
d'une manière assez officielle
n'explique pas n'explique pas cela il
n'a pas su
s'approprier le rôle de l'exécutif en
place installant l'ordre et rassurant la
population on va parler d'Emmanuel
Macron un juste pour compléter ce que
vous disiez Frédéric Bardella Le Pen
c'est complémentaire ou ses concurrent
je pense que c'est très complémentaire
en termes de discours good batcal je
reprends votre terminologie c'est vrai
que quand on demande dans un dans une
autre vague du baromètre il faut
Fiducial pour mâcher Sud Radio qui
incarne le mieux l'opposition Emmanuel
Macron c'est le rassemblement national
qui dévorce nettement la France
insoumise qui reste sur une critique
tribune initiale et c'est vrai je pense
qui a été dit sur Emmanuel Macron il y a
quand même gagné beaucoup de points
depuis le début des si je puis dire des
100 jours mais dans ce baromètre
l'ensemble des ministres montent
notamment ceux qui ont parlé et doit
Eric Dupont m'aurait dit a pris 9 points
et Gérald Darmanin on a pris trois un
cycle également Gabriel Attal et Olivier
Veyran les Français ont voulu des
paroles de la part de l'exécutif
Samia Emmanuel Macron Élisabeth borne et
bien elle s'en sort plutôt bien un
compte tenu du contexte 39% des sondés
ont une bonne opinion la première
ministre qui occupe la 14e place du
classement elle fait donc bien mieux en
fait que le Président de la République
qui lui perd un point d'opinion positive
à 32% le chef de l'État n'occupe que la
22e place du classement on a un peu
parlé déjà mais est-ce que ce résultat
vous surprend elle a quand même été très
exposé Elisabeth borne dans les deux
séquences qui viennent de s'achever sur
les retraites sur les sur les émeutes
alors elle a été exposée mais celui qui
a été en première ligne celui avec
lequel la relation des Français a été
envenimée c'est Emmanuel Macron on est
passé de la première ministre fusible à
un président paratonnerre ce qui est
vrai c'est que sur la longue durée quand
même on a un rétablissement assez
spectaculaire du couple exécutif
Emmanuel Macron a quand même beaucoup
repris de terrain il reste un président
structurellement minoritaire mais d'une
part la relation avec les Français c'est
décrispé quand je regarde des très
mauvaises opinions ça a baissé d'une
dizaine de points quand je regarde dans
le baromètre de la semaine dernière ce
qui n'approuve pas du tout son action on
a également une une chute et puis ils
aident borne elle fait si je puis dire
du François Fillon 2010 c'est-à-dire
qu'elle fait campagne pour rester à
Matignon c'était son interview du
Parisien de dimanche dernier j'ai
délivré je protège les Français et c'est
vrai que elle est créditée de plus de
visibilité pour l'instant que chef de
l'État qui se réserve la séquence très
et 14 juillet Isabelle est-ce que c'est
la fin du premier ministre bouclier
paratonnerre quand on va se résultat oui
c'était assez curieux non probablement
pas la Cinquième République et solide et
elle sait elle sait se sortir des
j'allais dire des pierres situations les
plus étonnantes mais non ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir qu'Elizabeth
borde qui avait été reçu de manière un
peu surprise par les Français ça
froideur ça dureté sans son côté pas du
tout charismatique comme on dit son
absence de charme en tous les cas de
temps assis de faire du charme sans
autre chose qui n'avait pas été accepté
peut-être rassure-t-elle maintenant les
Français du journal le sentiment que les
affaires continuent de fonctionner
qu'après il y a quand même la France
vient de traverser un nombre incroyable
de de tremblements
on peut remonter au covid ça a été quand
même les premiers tremblements les
gilets jaunes les réformes des retraites
et maintenant et maintenant les émeutes
des banlieues donc et face à cela
probablement la dureté la froideur le
sérieux la
capacité on le sent et ses problèmes
rassurer les Français donc ce n'est
probablement pas de la sympathie mais de
la bonne opinion et ça je crois que
l'expression est juste à dire que je ne
suis pas en train de l'aimer ou de ne
pas l'aimer mais j'ai une bonne opinion
de ce qu'elle est en train de faire donc
même s'ils sont là sont souvent
difficiles à interpréter là en
l'occurrence je pense que la question le
mot opinion est un mot compte chaque mot
que vous avez raison de le dire et là
sur les mots qui t'ont se baromètre pour
parler des enquêtes qualitatives je suis
frappé du décalage entre le bruissement
du microcosme comme disait Raymond Barre
à son époque sur un remaniement un
départ de la première ministre et le
fait que dans les enquêtes même les
Français critiquent à son égard ne
demande pas son départ ce n'est pas leur
question et dans le baromètre de la
semaine dernière le sujet dont les
Français avait le moins parlé dans leur
conversation c'était les rumeurs autour
d'un remaniement on va parler des 100
jours puisque c'est l'heure du bilan
avant de vous entendre on va écouter ce
qu'on disait ce matin Erik sotti le
président des républicains il détient
l'invité de France 2
il faut arrêter avec ces palabre avec
ses 100 jours où il s'est rien passé il
faut agir des actes sur l'éducation sur
la santé des actes aussi sur le
rétablissement des comptes publics 100
jours il s'est rien passé direction
est-ce que finalement c'est 100 jours ça
a été un peu un slogan qui devient un
exercice de communication raté
alors c'est un slogan probablement et
donc on avait déjà glosé sur le fait que
100 jours c'était terminé pour Napoléon
sur une mauvaise nouvelle Waterloo mais
on peut aussi on pouvait aussi dire il
sera rapprocher plus que Napoléon après
avoir subi pas mal de d'Avatar après
après c'est 100 jours avait a fait appel
à la démocratie et avait rappelé le
Parlement les philosophes qui étaient
des démocrates et ils s'étaient dit que
peut-être il fallait changer de
politique donc reprenons plutôt cette
cette comparaison et effectivement on
voit bien qu'après la vraie forme des
retraites l'idée de Emmanuel Macron
c'est de dire on efface tout et on
repart et c'est exactement l'idée des
100 jours on repart dans un sens plus
démocratique plus ouvert moins violent
et
en cela je trouve que dans les premiers
temps et dans ce qui a été réalisé il y
a eu du pour c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il y a eu des des mises
en place parce que on a dit je me suis à
l'époque on avait critiqué en 100 jours
et peut rien faire il n'a pas non plus
proposé de changer la France en 100
jours il a proposé de repartir d'un bon
pied vous savez de tourner la page et de
repartir donc il y a eu effectivement un
départ quand Isabelle borne les 36
textes qui ont été votés c'est vrai
l'argent dépensé c'est vrai d'ailleurs
les Français il y a eu alors là
l'inévitable ça c'est le charme de la
politique et de l'histoire il y a eu
l'événement totalement
inattendu puisque tout est venu d'un
drame sur un individu qui sont les
émeutes ok à la fois les cinq jours
auraient pu être vu comme un mouvement
indiscutable et d'une certaine manière
c'est 100 jours se sont terminés sont
ont été bouleversées par quelque chose
de inattendu qui à mon avis renverse le
slogan la communication brouille
brouille complètement tout analyse
comment ils sont vus ces 100 jours par
les Français en Amérique ce type qui dit
que ça n'a servait à rien Elisabeth
borne qui délivrer je vais être direct
il n'y a pas eu d'appropriation de ce
terme 100 jours jamais les Français dans
nos enquêtes qualitatives oui c'est ce
stream on dit oui il y a des 100 jours
ça a été un artifice de communication
qui a été le moment où il y a eu cette
décrispation entre Emmanuel Macron et
les Français on a eu cette période au
mois d'avril mai de très forte
visibilité du président qui a payé
puisque il a rétabli ses soutiens
historiques il est maintenant à 85% de
soutien ou de bonnes opinions de son
électorat du 10 avril 2022 la relation
avec des Français reste en venimeux mais
elle s'est décrispée mais on voit un
président qui a été très très visible au
détriment de ces ministres et pour
beaucoup de français Emmanuel Macron
reste le problème et pour ce tiers de
soutien c'est la solution mais c'est
vrai que il parlait de 100 jours et
d'apaisement et c'est vrai que les
événements en termes
urbaine alors on mis complètement de
côté la réforme des retraites des
casseroles on en parle plus si je puis
dire c'était quand même très central
encore au mois de mai et le fait que
maintenant les Français restent très
inquiets et en difficulté à avoir un CAP
de l'action du gouvernement même si
clairement la période en termes sont
d'agir est plutôt encourageante pour le
couple exécutifs
on peut voir dans 600 jours en tout cas
cette période à la fois une sorte de
réussite moi il me semble-t-il puisque
on l'a vu chez les sondages et un échec
parce que quelque part il y a eu un
déplacement de la préoccupation donc la
question n'est plus en jour mais la
question elle est fondamentale c'est
quelle France on veut tout simplement
une France de la discorde une France de
la ou de la guerre sociale et de la
guerre civile ça il y a des il y a du
boulot
[Musique]
et Samia avec la canicule le journal La
Marseillaise s'inquiète pour les
ouvriers sur les chantiers en plein
cagnard titre le journal qui s'est rendu
sur un chantier à Arles température
ressentie 37 degrés dans l'après-midi
des conditions de travail infernal et
pourtant le code du travail ne prévoit
aucune température limite au-delà de
laquelle un salarié peut exercer un
droit de retrait le gouvernement a
certes appelé les employeurs à la
vigilance avec un aménagement possible
des horaires de travail mais sur le
terrain ça reste très difficile avec des
délais souvent très serrés à tenir
canicule ou pas les clients s'en foutent
racontent un dirigeant du BTP dans ce
reportage à lire donc dans la
Marseillaise toujours pas de nouvelles
du petit miel le mystère s'épaissit
raconte Nice-Matin on est toujours à la
recherche du moindre indice titre aussi
le Dauphiné Libéré Émile deux ans et
demi a disparu je rappelle samedi
après-midi dans le hameau du haut Vernet
dans les Alpes de Haute-Provence on a
passé 12 hectares au peigne fin fouiller
tous les bâtiments du hameau on a même
fait venir un régiment spécialisé dans
la recherche de cash capable de détecter
le moindre bout de métal dans une une
botte de foin mais toujours rien
l'enquête va maintenant entraîner dans
une nouvelle phase l'analyse des
informations recueillies et notamment
des 1200 appels téléphoniques reçus la
presse régionale s'interroge sur
l'avenir des piscines privées est-ce un
luxe du monde d'avant c'est le dossier
du républicain Laurent ce matin la
sécheresse et les arrêtés de restriction
d'eau relancent le débat autour des
piscines privées mais où sont-elles ces
piscines la Charente Libre les a
répertoriées comme une par commune le
département en compte plus de 13000
essentiellement concentré dans les zones
les plus peuplées et les plus riches
est-ce qu'on pourra se baigner dans la
Seine c'est la question pose Paris
Normandie ce matin on sait qu'en 2025
après les Jeux Olympiques trois sites de
baignade seront aménagés à Paris est-ce
que ce sera possible en Normandie aussi
pourquoi pas répond un expert dans les
colonnes du journal qui imaginent des
zones surveillées au sud de Rouen à
condition d'améliorer encore la qualité
de l'eau un mot du Tour de France a
coupé le souffle la dernière étape
raconte la montagne ce matin il y a les
coureurs ont grimpé dans la fournaise
plus de 3000 mètres de dénivelé positif
entre Vulcania et Issoire une étape
remportée par l'Espagnol pélo Bilbao qui
signe sa première victoire sur le Tour
le tour qui s'élan sera aujourd'hui de
Clermont-Ferrand jusqu'à moulins une
grande première pour la Préfecture de
l'Allier qui n'a jamais accueilli le
cours merci Samia merci beaucoup
Isabelle verra version merci Frédéric
David merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
pour vous revoir cette émission sur
public sénat.fr et la prochaine
rendez-vous 18h Thomas Huc très bonne
journée à demain
[Musique]